une chef une brigade et des plats en
préparation pour le service du midi
pourtant l'entremet n'est pas un
restaurant comme les autres ici ce sont
des personnes en parcours d'insertion
qui
cuisinentes d'accord voilà tu me gardes
les boîtes pour la traçabilité s'il te
plaît le menu est conçu chaque jour par
Gaëlle qui supervise les préparations
mais contrairement à un restaurant
traditionnel elle ne passe quasiment pas
de commande tout est fourni par la
Banque alimentaire il faut alors faire
preuve de créativité des fois le matin
on va recevoir des fruits et légumes qui
sont vraiment abîmés donc on va les
faire on va changer les menus qui
étaient prévus et on va les préparer à
la place le restaurant solidaire a reçu
un approvisionnement de salicorne aussi
appelée cornichon de mer
alors au menu ce sera ton à la tomate sa
licorne et riz préparée par Adeline en
contrat d'insertion professionnelle avec
l'association Le Relais comme elle six
personnes travaillent au restaurant la
plupart ont très peu de connaissances
sur la cuisine parce que ça fait pas
partie des prérequis
on est je crois que personne ici est
issu de la restauration
du coup ça donne quoi au quotidien de
l'apprentissage on a l'impression d'être
avec des apprentis tout le temps un
apprentissage qui porte ses fruits Lydie
qui s'occupe du service a rapidement
rebondi sur une formation d'ambulancière
le restaurant lui a permis de développer
des compétences professionnelles mais
aussi son savoir-être je suis quelqu'un
d'assez timide donc je suis quelqu'un de
réservé dans le sens où je ne
connaissais pas la collectivité je ne
connaissais pas le sens de travailler en
groupe et c'est ce qui m'a fait
découvrir et ce qui est mal lâché un
petit peu dans plein de choses d'être un
peu plus souriante bonjour
comment allez-vous aujourd'hui
parmi les clients beaucoup d'habitués
selon les revenus de chacun le prix
varie entre 1 euro 50 et 12 euros
depuis l'ouverture il y a un an 600
bénéficiaires ont pu profiter d'une
sortie au restaurant à un tarif adapté